hello how are you today we're back after
three days did you miss me what did you
even watch
what what's available online you you
watched some common sense
financial advice i know you didn't you
get involved in a pyramid scheme
i know you did uh what'd you guys do let
me know in the comments below how were
ya
three days is a long time if honestly
it's nothing compared to what i used to
upload like once every three days
so nothing compared to that but we just
went daily as you guys
know finish the challenge 31 day
challenge otherwise i go bald
did that successfully which is why i
went and got a haircut
not a um scalping and so
it went very well though but i missed
you guys
i honestly did i took three days off it
was very nice
felt like i just slept the entire time
um besides just some basic
you know plotting b villain plotting
about you know the future of coffeezilla
of course
but most of the time i was just sleeping
chilling
eating just your everyday internet
detective stuff
guys but i want to talk about it yeah i
want to talk about uh
cyberpunk 2077. we're taking shots at
them
honestly the quality of coffeezilla
cyberpunk 2077
we got to talk about it shareholders
meeting of coffeezilla members
if you're a member of the coffeezilla
army meaning you're subscribed you've
watched a single video you've disliked
us
you're a member controlling interest yes
you dividends
and by controlling interest and
dividends i mean you have interest
no control so we're gonna talk about
that and then we're gonna talk about gme
what's going on it seems like the entire
world's melting down
i was talking to my barber today and
even they had heard of this they're like
yeah you hear about that gamestop stuff
and i'm like
yeah i decided it was a great idea to
take
off during the greatest potential moment
of my career it's a great
great idea so let's first talk about
cyberpunk 2077 guys we're taking shots
at one of the biggest in
you know games of the year obviously it
was a big flop
but it got me thinking these guys
strung along a set of loyal fans
and extracted value from them for
decades
or maybe a decade only to under deliver
and underwhelm people with the final
product
full of bugs and yet they walked away
with the bag
so i thought to myself stephen you've
been only at this for a year and look
what you can show for it i mean i don't
charge you nothing for this
look at this boys we're almost cyberpunk
2077 honestly the graphics are better
i'm just going to go out and say it
right now
no frame rates dropped right this is
1080p
no problem you can play this on your ps4
if you want this is what i'm talking
about guys
i just wanted to say to all you
cyberpunk fans who are looking like
you're just looking for
something to get reinvested in and to
spend all your time doing
coffeezilla videos hashtag zilla that's
my new ticker by the way i'm i'm turning
coffeezilla
into a stock because everyone cares
about stocks
nobody cares about youtube channels
rather than saying smash
like i'm gonna say we need a capital
investment
of 10k likes on this video right now
we're severely under allocated we've got
liquidity issues with our likes
we need a lot of likes guys so hashtag
zilla make it
make a trend make do do your thing guys
but yeah i wanted to say that i just
wanted to get that out there
and tell you guys about the vision of
coffeezilla because we're not just
the best damn looking youtube channel
out there right now
we're also investing heavily
in the product guys it's not just about
daytime
look every youtuber can film during the
day how about that night shot
what you know about that night shot you
know what i mean i mean you get what i'm
saying
we're also investing heavily in uh
a custom soundtrack for the channel
that's right guys
no more kevin mcleod no more
stock music maybe actually probably
still going to be a lot of stock music
for a while but we're reinvesting back
i want you guys to know that for every
click you add
into the investment pool the product's
getting that much better
guys for every time you press subscribe
boom something like this gets created
guys i wanted you guys to know this
because i know let's go back to the day
real quick
i know there's a lot of people who care
deeply
about graphics who care deeply
about the cyberpunk noir detective
aesthetic
and i want you guys to know that i'm
delivering i'm here for you
i want to um keep investing and if you
guys invest in me i will pay it forward
and that's what i kind of wanted to say
because
ladies and gentlemen we've gathered you
here today to talk about
dollar sign z-i-l-a
guys as you know our stocks have been
trending decidedly
in the um up you know the good direction
and that's good but i've recently been
watching videos like the spiffing brit
talking about the algorithm i've been
watching a bunch of uh
you know other youtubers and it one
thing is clear to me
when you look at what happened with
gamestop what's the secret
to growth it's not actually fundamentals
what we learned
in january was that the real value of a
stock is dependent on memes
it's dependent on you guys pointlessly
rallying around something
for no other reason than the sake of it
so i want to humbly ask you as your
humble leader and ceo we need to pump
this company
is it market manipulation to do that i
don't think we're regulated
which means it's time to pump it up guys
what does that mean in practice for you
well
the the thumbs button is a start but
then
there's a little something called a
playlist of my videos that you can just
leave on
in the background am i calling for you
to manipulate
my stock my my hypothetical company
channel stock yes absolutely
uh yeah i i am i absolutely
dude and that's why for this next month
we're going to try to pump this
this stock as much as we can listen
february 28th
don't ever like another one of my videos
don't ever do it again
just till february 28th that's when this
ends
we're gonna try to pump dollar sign
zilla as high as we can and then maybe
you know what
if it doesn't work out it doesn't work
out it's an experiment it's a test
so finally guys let's talk about the
content for the next month
so things are gonna be mostly the same
but we're gonna be talking about
gme this is something really passionate
that i'm so upset that i missed i feel
like an
idiot for missing it i took the worst
time chose the worst time to take off
um but we're gonna be talking about that
tomorrow because i really want to talk
about this robin hood
ceo um and i want to hear more from you
about what you want to see on the
channel guys we're going to be talking
about the super bowl ads
when they come out we're going to be
talking about anything
everything let me know what you guys
want to hear i just wanted to check in
with you see how you're doing
address the people i trust that just the
shareholders tell you guys our future
plans you know everything from a
dedicated soundtrack to
uh more scenes more storytelling more
investigations
and just tell you guys that i'm back
here to stay
uh thank you so much for your support
your support this month
it just has been honestly unbelievable i
know we joke around a lot but um
seriously incredible so thank you for
watching thank you for supporting i
appreciate you let's see if we can take
zilla to the moon baby